Et je lui ai tendu un stylo et un morceau de papier,
et il a commencé à écrire.
Mais quand j'ai vu le papier qu'il m'a rendu,
j'étais choquée.
Je n'ai pas reconnu son écriture,
il avait fait des fautes d'orthographe basiques.
Et je me suis dit qu'en tant qu'enseignante,
je savais qu'un étudiant pouvait s'améliorer de façon spectaculaire
très rapidement,
mais je n'avais jamais imaginé qu'un étudiant pût fortement régresser.
Ce qui m'a fait encore plus de peine,
a été de découvrir ce qu'il avait écrit à sa fille.
Il avait écrit :
« Je te demande pardon pour mes erreurs, et pardon de ne pas être là pour toi. »
Et c’est tout ce qu’il pensait devoir lui dire.
Et je me suis demandé comment le convaincre qu'il avait plus à dire,
des bouts de lui-même pour lesquels il n'avait pas à s'excuser.
Je voulais qu'il sente
qu'il avait quelque chose de valable à partager avec sa fille.
Chaque jour des sept mois suivants,
je lui ai rendu visite et lui ai apporté des livres.
Mon sac est devenu une petite bibliothèque.
J'ai apporté James Baldwin,
j'ai apporté Walt Whitman, C.S. Lewis.
J'ai apporté des guides sur les arbres, sur les oiseaux,
et ce qui allait devenir son livre préféré, le dictionnaire.
Certains jours,
nous restions assis pendant des heures en silence à lire tous deux.
Et les autres jours,
nous lisions ensemble, nous lisions de la poésie.
Nous avons commencé par lire des haïkus, des centaines de haïkus,
un chef-d'œuvre trompeusement simple.
Et je lui demandais : « Dis-moi tes haïkus préférés. »
Et certains d'entre eux sont assez drôles.
Par exemple celui-ci, d'Issa :
« Pas de panique, les araignées, je fais le ménage en dilettante. »
Et ceci : « Demi-journée passée en sieste, personne ne m'a puni ! »
Et celui-là, magnifique, sur le premier jour de neige :
« Cerfs se léchant l'un l'autre la livrée recouverte de premier givre. »
Il y a quelque chose de mystérieux et magnifique
rien que dans l'apparence d'un poème.
L'espace vide importe autant que les mots eux-mêmes.
Nous avons lu ce poème de W.S. Merwin,
qu'il a écrit après avoir vu sa femme travailler dans le jardin
et réalisé qu'ils passeraient le reste de leur vie ensemble.
« Laisse-moi imaginer que nous reviendrons
quand nous voudrons et ce sera le printemps.
Nous ne serons pas plus vieux que nous ne l'avons jamais été.
Les chagrins anciens se dissiperont comme la brume aurorale
à travers laquelle le matin émerge à lui-même. »
J'ai demandé à Patrick son vers préféré, il a répondu :
« Nous ne serons pas plus vieux que nous ne l'avons jamais été. »
Il a dit que ça lui évoquait un endroit où le temps s'arrêtait,
où il n'avait plus d'importance.
Et je lui ai demandé s'il avait un tel lieu,
où le temps dure pour toujours.
Et il a dit : « Ma mère. »
Lorsque vous lisez un poème à côté de quelqu'un d'autre,
le poème change de sens.
Parce que ça devient personnel pour elle, ça devient personnel pour soi.
Nous avons ensuite lu des livres, nous en avons lu tant !
Nous avons lu les mémoires de Frederick Douglass,
un esclave américain ayant appris à lire et à écrire par lui-même
et qui avait gagné sa liberté grâce à son alphabétisation.
J'avais grandi en voyant en Frederick Douglass un héros
et je voyais dans ce récit une histoire d'élévation et d'espoir.
Mais ce livre a mis Patrick dans une sorte d'état panique.
Il s'est arrêté sur une histoire racontée par Douglass :
comment, à Noël, les maîtres donnaient du gin aux esclaves
comme un moyen de leur prouver qu'ils ne savaient pas gérer la liberté.
Parce que les esclaves titubaient ensuite dans les champs.
Patrick a dit que ça lui parlait.
Il a dit qu'il y avait des gens en prison qui, comme les esclaves,
ne voulaient pas penser à leur état,
parce que c'était trop douloureux,
trop douloureux de penser au passé,
trop douloureux de penser à tout le chemin encore à parcourir.
Sa citation préférée était celle-ci :
« N'importe quoi, qu'importe, pourvu que j'arrête de penser !
C’est cette réflexion sempiternelle sur ma condition qui était mon tourment. »
Patrick a dit que Douglass était courageux d'écrire et de poursuivre ses réflexions.
Mais Patrick ne savait pas à quel point il ressemblait pour moi à Douglass,
par cette façon de continuer à lire, même si ça le mettait en panique.
Il a fini le livre avant moi,
le lisant dans un escalier de béton dépourvu de lumière.
Et puis nous avons lu un de mes livres préférés,
« Gilead » de Marilynne Robinson,
qui est une longue lettre d'un père à son fils.
Il en a aimé cette ligne :
« J'écris ceci en partie pour te dire
que si tu te demandes ce que tu as accompli dans ta vie...
tu as été la grâce que Dieu m'a accordée,
un miracle, et plus encore qu'un miracle. »
Quelque chose dans cette langue, cet amour, cette langueur, cette voix,
a réanimé en Patrick le désir d'écrire.
Et il se mit à remplir cahier sur cahier
avec des lettres à sa fille.
Dans ces lettres belles, complexes,
il s'imaginait avec sa fille en train de faire du canoë sur le Mississippi.
Il les imaginait trouver un ruisseau de montagne
avec une eau parfaitement claire.
En regardant Patrick écrire,
je me suis dit,
et je vous le demande maintenant à tous,
combien d'entre vous ont déjà écrit une lettre
à quelqu'un que vous pensez avoir laissé tomber ?
Il est tellement plus facile de sortir ces personnes de son esprit.
Mais Patrick est revenu chaque jour, face à sa fille,
soucieux de lui rendre des comptes,
un mot après un l'autre, avec une concentration intense.
Je voulais, dans ma propre vie,
me mettre en danger de cette façon.
Parce que le danger révèle la force des cœurs.
Permettez-moi de prendre du recul et de poser une question inconfortable.
Qui suis-je pour raconter cette histoire, comme dans cette histoire de Patrick ?
Patrick est celui qui a vécu avec cette douleur
et je n'ai jamais eu faim un seul jour de ma vie.
J'y ai beaucoup réfléchi,
mais mon message, c'est que cette histoire ne parle pas que de Patrick.
Elle parle de nous,
de l'inégalité entre nous.
Le monde de l'abondance
dont Patrick, ses parents et ses grands-parents
ont été exclus.
Dans cette histoire, je représente ce monde d'abondance.
Et en racontant cette histoire, je ne voulais pas me cacher.
Cacher le pouvoir que j'ai.
En racontant cette histoire, je voulais dévoiler ce pouvoir
pour ensuite demander :
comment réduire la distance entre nous ?
La lecture est un moyen de réduire cette distance.
Elle nous offre un univers tranquille que nous pouvons partager ensemble,
que nous pouvons partager de manière égale.
Vous vous demandez sans doute à présent ce qu'est devenu Patrick.
La lecture lui a-t-elle sauvé la vie ?
Oui et non.
Quand Patrick est sorti de prison,
son parcours a été atroce.
Les employeurs l'ont refoulé à cause de son casier judiciaire.
Sa meilleure amie, sa mère, est décédée à 43 ans
de maladie cardiaque et de diabète.
Il est devenu sans-abri, a connu la faim.
Bref, les gens disent bien des choses sur la lecture qui me semblent exagérées.
Savoir lire et écrire ne l'a pas empêché d'être victime de discrimination.
Cela n'a pas empêché sa mère de mourir.
Alors, que peut faire la lecture ?
J'aimerais finir aujourd'hui avec quelques réponses.
La lecture a rempli sa vie intérieure
de mystère, d'imagination,
de beauté.
La lecture lui a donné des images qui lui ont donné de la joie :
montagne, océan, cerf, givre.
Des mots qui ont un goût de monde libre et naturel.
La lecture lui a donné une langue pour ce qu'il avait perdu.
Combien sont précieux ces vers du poète Derek Walcott,
Patrick a mémorisé ce poème :
« Les jours que j'ai tenus,
les jours que j'ai perdus,
les jours qui croissent, tels mes filles,
depuis le havre de mes bras. »
La lecture lui a appris son propre courage.
Rappelez-vous qu'il a continué à lire Frederick Douglass,
alors même que c'était douloureux.
Il continuait à être conscient, alors même qu'être conscient faisait mal.
La lecture est une forme de pensée,
c'est pourquoi lire est difficile car il faut réfléchir.
Et Patrick a choisi de penser plutôt que de ne pas penser.
Enfin, la lecture lui a donné une langue pour parler à sa fille.
La lecture lui a donné l'envie d'écrire.
Le lien entre lire et écrire est si puissant !
Quand on commence à lire,
on commence à trouver les mots.
Et il a trouvé les mots pour leur inventer une vie à deux.
Il a trouvé les mots
pour lui dire combien il l'aimait.
La lecture a également changé la relation entre nous.
Elle nous a permis un peu d'intimité,
et d'élargir nos points de vue.
Et la lecture a transformé une relation inégale
en une égalité momentanée.
Quand vous rencontrez quelqu'un en tant que lecteur,
vous le rencontrez pour la première fois,
de manière fraîche, de manière neuve.
Vous ne pouvez pas savoir quelle sera son vers préféré,
quels sont ses souvenirs et ses chagrins personnels.
Vous voici devant l'enclos secret ultime de sa vie intérieure.
Et alors vous vous demandez : « Ma vie intérieure est faite comment ?
Qu'ai-je qui vaille d'être partagé avec quelqu'un d'autre ? »
Je veux conclure
sur quelques-uns de mes passages préférés dans les lettres de Patrick à sa fille.
« La rivière est ombreuse en certains endroits
mais la lumière transperce à travers les branchages...
Certaines branches sont lourdes de mûres.
Tends simplement le bras et tu pourras en cueillir. »
Et cette belle lettre, dans laquelle il écrit :
« Ferme les yeux et écoute les sons des mots.
Je connais ce poème par cœur
et je voudrais que toi aussi, tu le connaisses. »
Un grand merci à vous tous.
(Applaudissements)